في تصريح غير مفاجئ ترامب يعلن ترشحه
للرئاسه في الانتخابات المقبله وبعد
محاولتين فاشلتين الثالثه كانت ثابته نجاح
اطلاق صاروخ نصها الى القمر بعد 50 سنه
غياب
وتفاصيل الجديده حول وفاه الفنان الاردني
اشرف طلحه
اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
من يوم خسرته لانتخابات الرئاسه في عام
2020 والسؤال الابراج راح يترشح ثاني ولا
لا طبعا عم نحكي عن الرئيس الامريكي
امريكا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اعلان ترامب في خطاب في منزله في
فلوريدا بعد اسبوع من الانتخابات
الكبير
فقط
طبعا منصات التواصل الاجتماعي ليس بمفاجاه
طبعا كل الهاشتاجات حول العالم كانت عن
ترامب وعن اعلانه وكانت ترندين من وقت
خطابه حول العالم
من ابرز ردود الفعل بالطبع كان رد فعل
الرئيس الامريكي الحالي جو بايتنا الي رد
في تغريده قال فيها انه ترامب خذ البلاد
ايام ما كان رئيس وارفق بالتغريده فيديو
بيعدد من وجهه نظر بعيدا طبعا كل القرارات
السيئه اللي اتخذها وعمل لها ترامب
بس ردت فعل لافته اخرى على الاعلان جاءت
من داخل اسره ترامب نفسه تحديدا ابنته
ايفانكا اللي كانت بجانب والطوال لحمله
الاولى وخلال رئاستو كانت هي وزوجها جايه
كوشنر من كبار مستشعرين وكان برفقته
وبجانبه او كانوا الاثنين بجانبه طوال
الوقت ايفانكا اصدرت بيان بعد اعلان
والدها اعلنت في انها راح تبتعد عن
السياسه وقالت في بيانها احب والدي كثيرا
لكن هذه المره اختار ان اعطي الاولويه
لابنائي والحياه الخاصه التي نحاول بناءها
كعائله اضافت لا اخطط للانخراط بالسياسه
لكني مستمره في حب ودعم والدي وساقوم بذلك
دوما ولكن بعيدا عن عالم السياسي طبعا اخذ
خبر عدم دعم ايفانكا
وزوجته ولايه جديده كانت تتنقلته ايضا
وسائل الاعلام من فتره ولكن كان غير مؤكد
حتى بيان ايمان كان هذا اليوم اما زوجها
حتى هاي اللحظه هو ملتزم الصمت ولم يصدر
عنه شخصيا اي موقف رسمي يوضح موقفه من
ترشح حماه لا ولايه جديده
من 53 سنه او اكثر شوي حققت البشريه انجاز
علمي نزل العالم بيحكي فيه لليوم رائد
الفضاء الامريكانيسترونج خطا او الخطوات
للبشر على القمر
[موسيقى]
تانجو
[تصفيق]
مثل ما قال الارنب في جملته الشهيره في
هذا الوقت خطوه صغيره له كانت قفزه عملاقه
للبشريه لكنها قفزه ما كان العالم عارف
انه راح تستغرق اكثر من 50 سنه لا يعاد
تحقيقها لكن عموما ليله امس واخيرا وبعد
خمس عقود من رحلات اطول للقمر وبعد سنوات
من التاخير وازمات ميزانيه ومن مليارات
الدولارات كمان اطلقت ناس اقوى صواريخ
الاس اس باتجاه القمر منطلقا من مركز كندي
الامريكي للفضاء في فلوريدا في بدايه مهمه
ارتميس للعوده للقمر بعد 60 عاما وحوالي
100,000 شخص حضر الى المكان لمتابعه
المشهد المنتظر خصوصا في الشواطئ المحيطه
بمركز كنديه
7 6 5 5
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
سمسم
لمده
ثلاثه
ومن المقرر انه ترجع الكبسوله للارض وتهبط
في المحيط الهادي في ديسمبر الاول
عن هذا الامر في سؤال مهم جدا وكثار منا
حول العالم قاعدين عم يسالوه وهو ببساطه
ليه مهم نرجع للقمر اصلا وليه كل هذه
المحاولات شو راح نستفيد
لحتى نفهم او نحاول الاجابه على هذه
الاسئله معنا الان الدكتور حنا صباح نائب
رئيس الجمعيه الفلكيه الاردنيه اهلا بك
دكتور معنا دكتور خلينا نبدا مباشره احنا
اصلا ليه بدنا نرجع على القمر بعد 53 سنه
واصلا لو كان يعني في هدف بالفعل وجيه ليش
استنينا 53 سنه لحتى نرجع
شكرا طبعا هذا اول شيء بشكر قناتكم على
استضافه بهذا الحدث المهم همم بالطبع لازم
نعرف لو عدنا الى جذور المشكله ان اردنا
ان نفهم اي شيء علينا ان نعود الى جذور
المشكله وجذور القضيه هي تعود الى عام
1957 في 4 اكتوبر من ذلك العام تم اطلاق
اول قمر صناعي
سوفيتي ايامك كنز
طبعا هذا دشن بدايه ما يتعب بعصر الفضاء
وما ادعي لاحقا بسباق الفضاء
وطبعا سباق كان اساسا بين همم الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابقه والولايات المتحده
بالاضافه الى الدول التي تدور
طبعا همم كان هناك اسباب
اول همم
كلب
اول رجل
فاذا كان هناك مجموعه العمليات التفوق انا
ممكن نعتبرها في طرف السوفيات او روسي من
مقابل ارادت الولايات المتحده ان تسترد
اعتبارها في هذا الخصوص
قرر رئيس الاسبق جون كنديه انه يجب ان نصل
ان نضع انسان على سطح القمر قبل نهايه
ونجحني الان
بس هلا ليه احنا بعد 53 سنه بدنا نرجع
ولا 13 14
فضاء عام 2017
معقوله 17 اصبح الموضوع شيء عادي
القمر حتى لو بعدنا يعني بشر كمان مش بس
صاروخ
بدايه السبعينيات كان شيء خارج تطور خارج
السياق الطبيعي يعني من 1957 اول قمر صل
عليه 1969 19 سنه كان اول رائد فضاء على
سطح القمر
الان نتحدث عن سياقه مختلف تماما على فكره
الا لديها برنامج الفضائي همم
الهند لديها روسيا لديها ودول اخرى
بالتالي همم امريكا اصبحت تقول ومن معنا
لماذا يعني هؤلاء يمكن ان يسبقون مجددا
يعني
سباق علمي فضائي لا اكثر
طيب حضرتك امور اخرى يعني الشيطان وضع
انسان او مستوطنات دائما او طويله الامد
على سطح القمر هي خطوه نحو استكشاف الفضاء
العميقه بما فيها المريخ يعني القمر يعتبر
محطه متوسطه اول شيء يمتلك الكثير من
المعادن والاشياء التي يمكن ان نستخرجها
يعني تحميله التعدين في الفضاء وبضمنها
مثلا على سبيل المثال هيليوم 3 ماده عنصر
الهيليوم النظير الهيليوم رقم ثلاثه او
همم
هذا مهم جدا في موضوع الاندماج النووي وهو
متوفر بكثره على القمر وهناك امكانيه اصلا
يعني القطب الجنوبي الذي يستهدفه مشروع
ارتميس
القطب الجنوبي للقمر اي يحتوي ايضا على
الجليد الماء ومعادن متعدده فتوقع انه
الهدف من ارتميسون هو وضع مستوطنات بشريه
طويله الامر العيش طويل الامل طبعا
وبالتالي في ظروف طبعا جاذبيه ضعيفه على
سطح القمر سدس جاذبيه الارض وبالتالي يمكن
ان نختبر ايضا تاثيرات البيولوجيه والصحيه
الى اخره على موقف الانسان في الفضاء
وطبعا الخطوه التاليه المنطقيا بعد
مستوطنات القمريه هو الشيطان المريخ
لعمليه
في الوقت اللي اصلا طلعنا على الماء على
القمر بينما في كواكب اخرى مستكشفناها
ولسه ما بنعرف يعني اذا اذا كان ينفع ان
يكون في عليها حياه او لا فما بتاخذ هذه
اولويه ولا القمر اسهل ف همم يعني
نعم القمر اسهل بسبب قربه اولا
و2 يعني بنعرف تماما خواصه بشكل كافي طبعا
المستوطنات القمريه ستكون مغلقه بالمناسبه
لانه ليس هناك خلاف جوي على سطح القمر ولا
غلاف مغناطيسيه لكن هذه المستوطنات
المطلقات يفترض ان تحمي رواد الفضاء او من
سيعيش على سطح القمر من التاثيرات
الخارجيه من الاشعه الكونيه الرياح
الشمسيه الى اخره لكن ما اقوله هو لماذا
القمر مهم كون كون جاذبيه ضعيف اولا الارض
وايضا ما يدعى بسرعه »
يمكن ان ننشئ همم عمليات صناعيه لتصنيع
الصواريخ الفضائيه على سطح القمر وهذا
صواريخ الفرق الفضائيه ستكون كل فتره
اطلاقه نحو الفضاء الى المريخ مثلا اقل
بكثير من نظرتها على الارض لماذا لانه
الطاقه التي نحتاجها ستكون اقل وقود سيكون
افضل
متوسطه على القمر هو المحطه المتوسطه نحو
استكشاف الفضاء حاجه عن اهميه في التعدين
وفي المستقبل بالتاكيد ان موارد الارضيه
محدوده وسيكون لدينا يعني لا مفر من ان
نبدا بعمليه تعدين للفضاء واستخراج
المعادن والاشياء الثمينه من الفضائيه
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور حنا صابات نائب رئيس
الجمعيه الفلكيه الاردني
[موسيقى]
اسم الفنان الاردني الراحل اشرف طلفاح ما
زال في قوائم بحث الاردنيين والمصريين
والعرب ولسه مستمرين بمتابعه تطورات
والمؤسسات اللي وقعت مني يومين خلال وجوده
في مصر واللي الى الان ما انت تحقيقات
فيها بشكل نهائي فاللي صار انه فجاه نزل
خبر وفاه الفنان في مصر بعد اعتداء من
مسؤولين لاصار الناس كمان بتداولوا صور من
تقرير طبي قالوا انه راحل لكن هاي الاخبار
بسرعه المنافقتها سلطات المصريه والاردنيه
واللي نشرت بيانات رسميه وضحت فيها
التفاصيل النيابه العامه المصريه اللي
بتحقق في الحادث كشفت انه عثر عليه مغمى
عليه في البيت والنقل للمستشفى وكان ما
يزال على قيد الحياه والشرطه ما وجدت اي
اثر عنف في البيت من بره او جوه لكن جسمه
كان في اثار اصابات متفرقه وجروح وحروق
والكشف الطبي بين اصابته بنزيف في المخ
وتجمع الدموي وارتشاح في الرئه
المصريه قالت فيان انه للان لم تقف على
دلائل لاي شبه جنائيه وانتدبت الطب الشرعي
لاجراء الصفه تشريحيه وبيان سبب كيفيه
الاصابه لبيان مدى وجود ما يشير لوجود
شبهه جنائيه في وفاته بالنسبه للخارجيه
الاردنيه هي كمان بدورها اصدرت بيان اكدت
في متابعتها لا تطورات تحقيقات مع الجانب
المصري وانه تحقيقات الاوليه اثبتت انه ما
في شبه جنائيه وانه نتائج التحقيقات رح
تعلم فور الانتهاء منها والسفاره متابعتها
بالتنسيق مع شقيق الراحل وعائلته
نيجي لا لهم ماسك اخبار طرد ماسك لموظفين
في تويتر ما تزال اصدارها شاغله المنصه
خاصه وانه الاستغناء عن الموظفين عنده ما
توقف لحتى الان وشغال حتى علنا وعلى تويتر
في طرد موظفين بعض اللي طردهم مؤخرا
موظفين اختلفوا معه بالرؤوا بالراي او
ناقشوه في شيء علنا في تغريدات وتفاجئوا
بعدها بايميلات استغناء عن خدماتهم لكن
امام كل هذه الاخبار الناس انصدمت من
ساعات بتغريده غير متوقعه من ماسك في ظل
الظروف الحليليه ماسك تصور الى جانب شخصين
وعلق وقال ارحب مجددا بل لجنه
ورجع ورجع كده كتب بعدها وقال انه همم مهم
الواحد يعترف باخطائه انه طردهم كان واحد
من اكبر اخطائي زي ما قال ماسك واللي
بيشوف الصوره طبعا بيقول اوف شكله مصر
يعني حسبي غلطه بيعترف على الملا لكن اذا
بتدق شويه في الصوره بتبين الحقيقه لو
ركزتوا شوي في الوجوه اللي في الصوره راح
تحسوا انكم شايفينهم قبل هيك ولو نسيم وين
خليني اذكرهم
لك
اللي بنصور ماسكه وهو يرحب فيهم هم نفسهم
الاثنين اللي عملوا مقلب بالاعلام يوم
استحواذ ماسك على تويتر ووقفوا قدام
الشركه وعملوا انهم مفصولين وطلعوا بالاخر
لا موظفين ولا شيء ووقتها ماسك الشارع في
التنكيت على الموضوع في تغريدات بعد من
فتحت القصه ويعني كثير من وسائل الاعلام
مالات حالها موقف محرج جدا الحقيقه في هذا
الوقت عموما يبدو انه اليوم ماسك حابب
يستعين فيهم مره ثانيه للرد على كل اللي
لسه بنتقدوه على مسلسل الطرد اللي شغال
فيه واللي ما وقف ولا شكله ناوي يوقف
قريبا
قلنا طبعا اسابيع راجعين الان نشوف ارقام
كرونه في الصين زايده مقاطع كثيره متداوله
من هناك بخصوص القيود والاجراءات الخاصه
وانه الصين بتتبع سياسه صفر كوبد يعني اول
ما بيتم رصد اي حاله بيصير فورا اغلاق
وفحوصات للكل تجديد للاجراءات الساعات
الماضيه بتسجل او كم تسجيل في الصين اكثر
من 20 الف اصابه جديده بكرونا ومن
الاجراءات اللي تم اتخاذها مثلا اغلاق
جميع اللي على اللي فيها طبعا لانه رصد او
تم رصد اصابه واحده داخل الجامعه
ما في احد لا يدخل ولا يخرج جوانزو وجنوب
الصين من المناطق اللي فيها تفشي بزياده
والسلطات اعلانات اغلاق كامل في المدينه
فحطت الحواجز ونزلت السلطات واغلقت المحال
والاماكن العامه لكن السكان يبدو انه فاض
فيهم الكيلو خلاص مش قادرين يتحملوا اكثر
من هيك ونزلوا للشوارع وكسروا باشو ورفضوا
الاغلاق
[تصفيق]
عشان
جميل
حلقه اليوم من تفاعلكم القاكم غدا باذن
الله شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]